someday all right welcome to another
edition of ask Evan episode number ten
that's an interesting song one of my
favorites and probably the slowest one
that I have on my belief playlist is by
pete seeger we shall overcome a really
important song in the Equal Rights
Movement I just came back last night i
watched Selma which is a movie with
Martin Luther King about equal rights
for black people and Pete Seeger was was
instrumental in that movement as well
and see no singing songs and what I love
about him was using his art using his
music as a way to shine light on a cost
and I love martin luther king I love
Pete Seeger I think as entrepreneurs you
should be you should be using your voice
a spread light on a cause as well and
and he got people involved right you
want to sing along to the cash music but
he also told people what the sing before
was coming up so it's very inclusive
very loving and I love Pete Seeger so
it's a slowest song on my playlist but
it also is inspiring for me and that's
why it's there and I'm ready to start
ask Evan number ten so you may have
noticed for those of you loyal viewers
believe nation that the orchid is back
in the picture Christina you may notice
here we have two buds happening here we
got to zoom in on this two buds that are
coming up here so it's going to be
flowering and you get to see the
progression along the way it is a
Frappuccino plus lemon water day and I
want to start with a question for you
guys I think that might make this a
tradition I'm thinking about my youtube
videos and you know I don't put a ton of
effort into the SEO of them I think a
little bit about the titles but i don't
i don't do keyword research I don't put
the description
don't fill that out I don't have a
transcript I don't have time stamps I do
a little bit of tagging but not a lot
and I get a lot of people consistently
right into me every week to say Evan I
love your videos you should have more
views I don't understand why there's not
more views than all your videos and
that's a great problem to have right I'm
not complaining and I'm wondering if the
SEO could be better and if you have
experience with that I love to hear your
comments below or you can shoot me a
message you know for me is the juice
worth the squeeze right is it going to
be worth the investment cuz it's not
going to be me doing it so I have to
bring somebody on board hire somebody to
help me with that am I going to get
enough of a return by optimizing the
titles of the more I'm putting the text
in the description all that stuff to
make it worth my wat is it worth it I
want your experience your answers your
suggestions leave a comment below let me
know now let's get to your questions
first up is a newsletter subscriber
Isaac who writes in to say hey Evan I've
seen some of your videos on YouTube the
passion in your words brought me
motivation and hope I have a goal of
creating the best pet retail store
problem is I have no clue where to start
I'm 20 hate my job and broke if you
would recommend as soon as possible i'd
appreciate the guidance keep changing
lies my friend and may God continue to
bless you Isaac loving it loving the
passion love in the message of hope all
capital letters and I on Sega see you
building a business around the word hope
and what I'd love for you to do the
start is start by getting some
experience you have no idea where to
start get some experience you know you
start a retail shop that's expensive
stuff right to get your own location to
hire staff to pay for rent to pay for
all the utilities to buy all the
products that's expensive stuff so what
I would do is start by getting the job
at a leading pet retailer right now
learn the industry learn the suppliers
learn what works learn what's not
working get as close to the entrepreneur
founder as possible take on as many
projects as possible to develop your
skills to get paid while you're making
mistakes and then when you're ready to
go I would build a brand around hope
since that's what you capitalize here I
would make your pet store all about hope
and show show dogs who are who've been
rescued and have a
to help some of those dogs at as well
and maybe you donate a certain
percentage of your your revenue or
profits to the Humane Society you're
actively campaigning to help the Humane
Society or promoting any campaigns for
lost dogs like messages of hope make
that clear because when I go to a pet
store it looks like every other pets
towards boring doesn't mean anything to
me so start with that message of hope
make that mean something to me tell me
the stories that you're involved with
helping these dogs out and I'm more
likely to want to buy from you I'd also
try to figure out how can you start
without a retail store that may be your
end goal but it's going to cost you a
lot of money to start that up so how can
I start smaller how can I start with an
online shop selling some specific
products and learning the market making
some contacts and connections and
expanding that to building a name in the
community and open your own store so one
get a job learning the industry getting
paid to make mistakes to start cheap
start online start small learn the
market and then three build a message
around hope that builds a brand that
attracts people that makes people are
magnet to you just like they are to me
for believe if they're thinking hope and
they love dogs to come in to you first
all right next up is a YouTube viewer
need poon who writes in to say hi thanks
for the video i have a question is it
never too late sony people looking at
your picture there it looks like you're
still a pretty young dude i don't know
how old you are there but it's kind of
hard to see but you're not looking like
you're you're in your 60s or 70s okay
dude it's never too late to start there
are so many examples of famous
entrepreneurs who started later in their
career you look at Ray Kroc from
mcdonalds who was in his 50s and had
diabetes and had all these problems with
this health and and he was still
convinced that the the best years were
ahead of him right hehe he had arthritis
and and he was selling milkshake
mixtures for a living and he left that
to create mcdonalds and and become one
of the biggest brands in the world I
told to serve Harland Sanders who
started KFC and he didn't have
successful he was in his 60s you know
it's never too late to start the key
thing is that you are passionate what
you're doing and it helps people in some
way everybody has his limiting beliefs
okay we all have them you're telling
yourself a story as to why you can't
accomplish something for some
people lets you know I'm too old I can't
do this and you may believe that because
you're 25 years old that's too old to
start you may look at you know Internet
entrepreneurs and you're starting when
they're 13 14 15 you think why I'm 25
I'm Way too old as long as you believe
that it's not going to work for you i
had the same thing when i was when i was
starting my first business it was the
opposite i thought i was too young i
thought hey i'm selling to these guys
three times my age i'm too young they're
not going to listen to me that i can
take me seriously they're scientists
with PhDs i'm a university student who
knows nothing about science how I gonna
sell these guys on my software aid and
that really hope held me back I didn't
want to talk to anybody on the phone I
would only want to do email conversation
would double check every email with my
partner to make sure that I was saying
the right things and so I didn't grow
because of that because that limiting
belief held me back and it wasn't till I
discovered that these guys don't care
how old I am as long as I can help them
if I can help them solve a problem
they're willing to listen to me and when
I overcame that barrier I managed to
break through you know I burst through
the fear that I had and started making
sales and started getting contact so we
all have these stories that we're
telling ourselves that yours is I'm too
old to start well you're not and the
easiest way to break through is to find
stories of people who you look up to who
show you that you're not too old right
you can look at people who started in
the 30s in their 40s and 50s or 60s or
70s had success put that up on the wall
look at that every day create an
environment that is supportive that
builds you up that makes you feel like
you can go on to accomplish anything
because you can so it's not too late to
start start right now okay next up
another youtuber the official faces
factory rights in the same hi I'm Dean
with the government sector but my
company for venture capital I'm going
for an e presentation okay the Q&A what
do I need to wear to impress them and
what's the first word to come out of my
mouth because I'm dealing with the big
guys I don't want to miss that chance my
company really needed the deal to
continue my business thank you great
question and one that I can empathize
with I used to be in the venture capital
business and I've also sold to
governments and sold big deals in the
government center
big companies I can tell you this this
is this is with absolute certainty it's
much more about how you wear something
than what you wear it's much more about
how you say something than what you say
it's about the confidence and knowing
that you can help them so you know don't
go in looking like a total slob but if
wearing a three-piece suit makes you
uncomfortable and you're walking in
there and you're feeling nervous and
you're fidgety and like it's too tight
and the tie is choking you that's going
to come out right people will notice
that that you're uncomfortable and it
raises flags it makes people feel
uncomfortable as well I'd much rather
have you go in wearing something that
you're comfortable with it could be even
business casual could be a shirt with a
sweater something that you feel at home
in again not total slob but it's much
more about how you wear it then what you
wear same thing for what you say it
doesn't matter so much what the first
word out of your mouth is doesn't matter
about exactly what sentence you say it's
more about how you say it are you
confident do you believe in it I
remember when I first started making the
videos you know I wanted to be perfect i
had to be perfect every line i said was
scripted had to be amazing you know a
well thought-out took me a long time to
write the script and then I would be
sitting there thinking you know
explaining it and talking and trying to
remember what it was that I said and you
may see me looking up and and being
uncertain with it and the delivery site
right the content was fantastic but the
delivery suck and as a result people
didn't care as much even though i might
have said better things then but what i
said now maybe you know that the results
aren't the same because now I can speak
with a lot more conviction in confidence
than I could before because i have
practice so don't worry so much about
saying the exact right thing and instead
practice on having the confidence so
that whatever you do say comes out
eloquently so a couple things to help
you with this okay this is what helped
me when I was going into big deals and I
was nervous talking to their big guys
who knows that make your break
opportunity you don't miss your one shot
right the first thing is know that you
can help them the thing that always ease
my mind when I was going to talk to big
customers even now and I'm talking to a
big brand I'm going
and talking to Microsoft about a big
campaign we're working on I feel like I
can help them and I just try to remember
that like what I have to share you I'm
going in there may be a room or 20
people I'm going in knowing that I can
help them that I have a solution that
I'm confident and that can help them
that puts me at ease yes it's a little
big deal yes I still when I close it yes
I'm still nervous but knowing that I
have something that can work for them
makes me feel just a little bit more
confident the second thing is practice
practice your presentation practice your
speech practice your pitch and try to
practice in front of somebody and if
it's not in front of a person start by
practicing in front of the plant right
I'm sitting here talking to mr. orchid
explaining my pitch right it seems silly
but it helps practice talking to your
cat practice talking to your dog ideally
then you can bring somebody else in
their room you know me lead starting
practice talking in the mirror get your
pitch down so that again you may miss
parts of it it may not be perfect you
may not use the exact same words every
single time but you want to practice it
so that when you get out there and you
start talking to them you're you're
eloquent you're confident you're
passionate you're determined and they
can feel that right and they're gonna
care again much less about what you say
and how you say when I do these videos
now even now I mean I've had a lot of
practice doing these videos before I
come on and do a video if I'm doing a
one-minute Monday from doing a famous
friday / mentoring specific question I
will usually look at the question and I
will walk around for a little bit
walking back and forth practicing what I
want to say hidden kind of the key
points that I have in my mind muttering
to myself you know trying to get into it
and then they go on film and that may
only take me you know five minutes
before each video now because I get used
to it what I'm doing the ask Evans show
it's actually a lot less I'm more likely
to screw up a big mistake I really just
look at the question think for for 30
seconds and then start recording but
that comes with practice to summarize
okay number one first of all congrats an
opportunity and really excited for you
number one much less about what you say
and and what you're wearing and more
about how your
saying it and how you're wearing it and
to practice get some experience practice
/ / / / / drill it to the point where
you're feeling confident knowing that
you got that you guys can go in and help
them that will help seal the deal good
luck let me know how it goes i want to
hear some positive news keep believing
let's keep the show rolling next up
turning over to Twitter looking at a
question from that home who wrote in to
say Evan Carmichael how do I get started
man could you put me on the right track
I'm a big fan of your videos and what
you do by the way thank you know whom I
appreciate it i hope i pronouncing your
writing your name properly listen you
get started at the start you don't have
to make this too complicated too
confusing you start by following
something that you love to do get lost
explore find something that you can can
can consume yourself in and and just
love doing and you're gonna find a
couple things okay and I've told these
stories a couple times but you're going
to find some things that you do that
you're all excited by ear you love the
opportunity and then it fizzles out you
know for me uh some examples where I
went I went rock climbing okay I went
rock climbing and and I hated it okay so
some things you'll try you're gonna hate
it what rock climbing the thing is in my
crotch you know I'm afraid of heights
I'm fighting it I'm not having fun I
know if I fall off you know that person
has me but I it's I'm fighting it I
don't like it I'm not going to do it I'm
done with rock climbing nothing against
you guys who love rock climbing just not
for me then I tried snowboarding and
snowboarding was something that I love
doing and and I got into it and for two
years I was killing it and I you know I
want I was going every day snowboarding
I was always finding ways to reschedule
my meeting so I can get to the local
snowboarding hill to get my practice in
and I was learning jumps and I was doing
my s turns and finding ways to duck out
so I can go snowboarding but then that
fizzled you know now I'm going to go a
couple times in a year you know maintain
my skills and and that's it you know I
don't have the love for it anymore and
then I did salsa and salsa was something
that I still love doing I'm still lost
in it I DJ I teach I've become invested
in a company it's become a business
where it started off as a hobby you know
ten years later
I still love doing it I'm still actively
involved this is the progression need to
take with your ideas you're going to try
some ideas that will not work that
you'll hate immediately cool move on
you'll find some that you love for a
little bit and it's a quick rush and
then you realize this isn't for you
awesome don't stay in that if you're not
loving it get out do something else and
then you want to find the ones that you
love doing that you get lost in that you
can do you know you look down it's nine
o'clock you look up at six or talk at
nine you like what happened to the day
you're consumed by what you're doing you
love it so much and then figure out how
do i add value to people's lives we can
combine that that's a successful start
man that's how you get started so so
start to explore start figuring out what
you can get lost in and one last tip is
I would model success and start looking
at famous entrepreneurs look at their
stories look at how they got started get
inspired get inspired by people who are
doing big things and that make you want
to go out and try stuff because we're
often so locked into these this world
that we create for ourselves that keeps
us in place and by surrounding yourself
with people doing big things even if
it's just reading books watching videos
listening to interviews whatever it is
get inspired by greatness to make you
want to get out of your comfort zone and
do something okay next up last question
already another youtuber Joey car rights
in to say hi Evan I had a product in
inventory but have yet to make any
significant strides for substantial sale
can I or someone representing me present
my product directly to a local big box
retail store manager great question and
yes absolutely now there are three
suggestions are going to give you okay
the first one is you can go direct you
can go yourself you can look for
opportunities to present all of these
major big-box guys will have a way to
reach them sometimes it'll be an email
sometimes it'll be a phone number
sometimes I'll have open houses where
you can submit an application this is
what I did to get my the company I
invested in a salsa dancing company we
made a DVD we got on the shopping
channel there was open open call you
submit your business plan to them how
they can make money from it and then the
best ones that they like in different
categories they have a one day meet up
at a hotel you go you have ten minutes
with a buyer and they decide if they
like you or not so the couple phase
process one is sending them out an email
with with your plan and then the next
round is getting to meet the buyer at a
hotel or a certain day and then from
there they decide that they want to
bring you on or not and so it's you know
making sure you have the right plan
making sure you know when the dates are
going to be making sure you monitor
those pages for opportunities to connect
with them okay so that's one way you can
do it yourself and to make that work you
have to make sure that you have you know
a great plan because they're going to
get pitched tons of different
opportunities my background was in
venture capital was then seen business
plans knowing which plans were not
working and so that experience helped us
get that first d look at that first
meeting and we are way more professional
than most of the people who were
submitting applications so you want to
make sure you do your work look for some
examples really upgrade your skills to
write a good plan to pitch these guys
number two is you can use a website
called jigsaw and is jigsaw calm with I
think recently changed to connect let me
look it up connect datacom and basically
it allows you to find people around the
world in different positions so if
you're trying to get into walmart you're
trying to find the buyer for a certain
first certain region in walmart you can
look that up you can find that person
you can get their name their phone
numbers and email address and you can
reach out to them again when you do it
you ought to make sure you're sending
them value it's the right person to
contact your sending number a quality
business plan you're not harassing them
you're not spamming them right and so
again you could do that yourself we can
have somebody do it for you and the
third thing is connecting with the
company that specializes in this there
are there are companies there are
consultants there are people you can
work with who that's their business is
trying to get orders from big box stores
and they take a cut sometimes we'll ask
for some money up front sometimes
they'll make it a mix of of some kind of
retainer up front plus percentage of
sales sometimes it'll be all victory
based right usually be more expensive
longer term right they'll take a cut of
anything that you sell through that big
box store but they have connections
they've done it before and so that's
another option to go if you don't feel
comfortable that you know the business
planning skills you don't want to learn
that you don't want to do the pitching
yourself then partner up with someone is
coming to
business to help you do that or make an
alliance with one of these brokers who
that's your area of expertise what's
that's what they do all day long that's
what they specialize in so you can get
your product into the big box stores
good luck whoo another episode Aaron
thank you guys so much for watching if
you liked this video you can subscribe
to the channel and make sure to answer
my question in the comments back to the
very top about SEO video you know titles
descriptions timestamps let me know is
it worth it resources I should be
checking out I'd be very appreciative
you can share some knowledge spread some
light for me thank you guys so much for
watching I'll see you soon
hi Raquel English here with mermaid
junkutv are you on Evans newsletter
subscription if not you should be I read
every single one and you should too ciao
you